[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist i
serve as the director of the hayden
planetarium right here in new york city
at the american museum of natural
history and today's episode we're going
to talk about the science
in the space force
space force
of course i got my co-host chuck nice
jack hey just a reminder to everybody i
serve as the director of my town home
here in jersey okay
there you go there you go and one of our
old-time favorites here on star talk to
help us navigate the space force we've
got my friend and colleague and geek in
chief charles liu charles
hi so good to see you and i'll just uh
tell you that i'm the director of
absolutely nothing okay
that means you're getting work done you
see
i hope
yeah you can be productive or you can be
creative but you can't be both so i
don't know so what we're going to talk
about is the space wars oh allow me to
remind everyone that charles is a
professor at the city university of new
york on staten island and he's an
associate in our department of
astrophysics at the american museum of
natural history so i get my dose of
charles whenever i want
and i get a dose of you whenever i want
you know it works out great we're
talking about the space force and later
in this program we're going to bring on
major general deanna burke
she's a general in the u.s space force
yes this is real
in our third segment we're going to talk
about space junk
with the general and we're going to
bring in an aerospace engineer who
specializes in space junk yes
who's a friend of star talk he's been on
before so let's get let's get started
here so so i don't know how many people
you know read my 600 000 page book
which one neil which one which
it's called accessory to war
the unspoken alliance between
astrophysics and the military it's all
in there it's what what role
uh being an expert on the universe has
to what that has to do with any kind of
uh
military
operation
military hegemony uh on on
domination whatever people were doing in
the history of civilization there was an
astronomer right there because the sky
enabled people to navigate
and charles what is the greatest
navigation system ever devised
what you mean
the sky and no navigation
you mean gps gps thank you that's the
one you're looking for okay
gps yes
you can find gram you know the
directions to grandma's house so
all this is uh is pivots on navigation
and there's always some kind of
astronomer astrophysicist in the mix and
so uh if anyone is interested in sort of
the the deep history of that
relationship it's all in the book or you
can just listen to this show and not buy
the book okay
you can do either let me just tell you i
got a little note from your uh publisher
here neil shut up
[Laughter]
keep pushing the book
you're the only guy i know who actually
promotes this book by going hey you know
you don't have to get it no because i
can't i'm not making people spend any
money you know
you can listen to this show and dad just
don't get the book just don't get the
book yeah no no get the book people uh
so we had a a star talk on national
geographic episode where we sort of
introduced the concept of a space force
before it was formally designated as
such and we showed some footage of me
visiting the thule air force base in
greenland greenland oh my gosh which is
not green at all it's not it's cold
that's what i'm talking about what i
liked about that episode was uh neil got
off the plane in the beginning of the
episode he had on like a jacket it was
kind of old
yeah yeah i was kind of close hello
hey what's happening
i got this i got it by the end of the
episode neil you couldn't see his face
he had four parkers
chuck i don't think you could resist the
statement
why there are no black people in here
let me tell you something there was not
one brother
not one brother in greenland
and they had and neil showed up and
there and they were like oh wow what are
you doing here
well at that tool air force base in the
top of the world they monitor satellites
and missile threats and anything from
space that could be coming over the pole
and now that is under the auspices of
the space force and we're going to find
out more about how that works from uh
general burt uh later in the show but
right now charles i want to get some
physics out of the way before we break
into that second segment um you know we
we can think of ways you might destroy a
satellite if there's any kind of
military conflict on orbit
and
uh something that shows up in a lot of
sci-fi stories um even movies that are
not sci-fi just phi okay
is the emp
electromagnetic pulse the
electromagnetic pulse now that's that
made a cameo in uh ocean's eleven you
might remember that okay it was an emp
that took out the power grid in las
vegas when they
um when they robbed the the safe also
there was an emp in the matrix the
matrix yes of course okay nebuchadnezzar
the nebuchadnezzar and all the the
sentinels were coming at them and they
they can't attack them one by one but an
emp can take them all out that's exactly
what they showed so charles yes my my
fellow physicist yes tell me about emps
what are they and why why do they
destroy machines and not people no it's
very simple
electromagnetic pulse is a burst of
radiation it could also contain
electrons but mostly
it's high energy radiation that will
disrupt electronics think about it if
you're ever listening to radio and a
lightning strike a lightning bolt hits
nearby for a moment your radio goes
brief bit of static the bottom line is
and we'll keep this super short the
electromagnetic
and electromagnetic pulse can simply be
created by detonating a very large
nuclear device
maybe a few tens or maybe a few hundred
miles up from the earth's surface and if
it's a powerful enough burst it will
blast so much pulse out into the
environment that it will fry any
electronic devices communication systems
or power grids in its vicinity so you
wind up so you're not talking about the
blast the physical blast you're talking
about the electromagnetic blast that's
associated with those bombs as well
that's right the the physical blast is
bad enough but there were some nightmare
scenarios back in the 80s where maybe an
enemy could take a huge bomb put it a
couple hundred miles up above the
continental united states
detonate it create an electromagnetic
pulse from coast to coast and wipe out
all communications and command and
control of the united states before a
single shot was fired
wow
electromagnetic pulse
so can we protect against
electromagnetic pulses yes to some
extent
uh the military knows how to harden
things to protect it from electric
magnetic pulse for example air force
hardened in quotes i like the way you
said that's right you said you uttered
that charles that's right that was that
was it charles this word is in quotes
yeah air force one for example is
hardened uh against emp but
unfortunately you can only do so much uh
before you will be overwhelmed if the
blast is too close or too powerful so is
this the famous faraday cage you can
stick it in you can help that will help
yes when you surround something uh with
metal but also don't forget uh tin foil
hats
different kind of pulse yeah that's a
different kind of pulse yeah absolutely
very effective
right so if you surround something with
a a metallic
frame
then the electromagnetic energy gets
stopped at that
outer surface right it sort of goes
around the outside something called the
skin effect the skin effect yeah very
cool very cool so if you want uh
satellites to survive an enemy attack
not by missiles but by an emp you'd want
to harden them in this way
yes for example there are other ways
so in the all the examples of this that
you have seen
in film have they done it right like how
about in ocean's 11 no i mean that
wasn't wasn't a bomb it was just
something that made the pure
electromagnetic pulse and apparently
this high energy radiation is not
melting the flesh off of the people who
detonate the switch unfortunately
you're a morbid dude have you have you
have you gotten this checked out
no you know i haven't you're still it's
still rampant with me it's just
happening man i can't help it
okay
um so so how is it that you can have a
pulse that doesn't then harm the people
who engage the pulse
a pulse is electromagnetic and therefore
it generally passes through the human
body if it's strong enough it can
scramble you cause you you know injury
the way like a radiation burn might but
generally speaking it takes much less to
damage an electronic system than it does
to damage
us
okay
all right all right
i can get that plus i presume if you
design an emp detonator you could tune
the frequencies to be just what would be
most damaging to a circuit
and
not to whatever might be the
electrochemistry of the human body it's
possible but it's a little harder to do
that though uh when you have a bomb
going off especially a nuke uh a lot of
radiation goes out from a lot of ranges
that's just the way it goes
yeah and you just take it and so yeah
human beings are under threat but a
human being at a certain distance will
wind up being damaged less than an
electronic device at that same distance
or even at a greater distance right
right
okay all right
all right cool well we got to take a
quick break and when we come back
charles you can stay with us and we're
going to bring on
a major general deanna burt who's who's
in the space force this is
i don't know where the space force
where's where are you
space well um the air force has
designated a march
uh which is based on a piece by john
philip souza called the invincible eagle
however no lyrics have yet been written
oh oh
okay so this is waiting for for the
moment we're waiting for charles to
utter the lyrics
that's much better than mine which was
just space force nothing but space force
[Laughter]
all right guys we take a break we're
gonna come back with an actual member of
the actual us space force on star talk
we're back star talk we're talking about
the space force
space force and i got my co-host chuck
nice jack hey hey hey chuck you're still
going to chuck nice comic thank you sir
yes i am you are indeed and
and our resident geek in chief for a
return visit his nth return visit we say
mathematically because we've lost
account
charleston plus one
uh charles liu always good to have you
back here charles thanks so much we're
talking about the space force and for
this segment we are bringing in an
actual physical human being person who's
part of the space force major general
major general deanna bert deanna welcome
welcome general welcome to star talk
yeah thanks dr tyson it's a pleasure to
be here with you guys today excellent
and i've got you
now that we're just using uh our actual
titles please i am lord nice okay lord
nice
[Laughter]
your lordship yeah we've we got dr lou
dr tyson major general burt and lord
knight okay organized uh so just some of
you your pedigree i mean you guys have
these titles which are very precise in
the military world but this sounds so
impressive just listening from the from
the outside so as i as i have it written
here your commander of the combined
force
space component command of the u.s space
command did i get that right yes sir you
did cool cool and you're also vice
commander of space operations command at
vandenberg vandenberg space force base
in california wow yes sir
that's different from
the commander of vice that's different
from being vice commander that was that
was my former position
that's what i used to do different
operations there
and you and you were formerly at
peterson uh uh space for air i knew it
as peterson air force base now peterson
space force base colorado i visited that
uh when i served on the board of the
space foundation and correct me um
general is that where they control uh
gps satellites is that yes sir out at
shrever space force base that's about 12
miles uh east of peterson okay both in
colorado for sure there it is so so tell
us what is what is your
actual role as a major general in the
new u.s space force
so thanks dr tyson i think again we
talked about that i have two hats so my
first hat that you mentioned i'm a
functional component command working
directly for general dickinson the us
space command commander so
i command control about 17 000
military and civilian personnel to
provide combat space effects to the
other combatant commands the
multi-domain fight uh and our coalition
partners uh and the nation just to be
clear multi-domain means other branches
of the armed forces is that correct
absolutely so okay again space is not
just done for space's sake it's done to
be able to provide those war-winning
effects uh both to the nation and to the
other services so they can fight and win
uh the fights that they come against
on the service side though my other hat
that you mentioned and i'm a vice
commander i also work on the generate
sustain
uh and present for the air space force
and how do we put forces together so i'm
really it's good that i have the two
hats and one way i'm looking at how do
we make sure the forces are ready uh to
be presented to as the vice commander to
then present to the combatant command in
my joint hat to do that war fighting
mission
so you have do you have a degree in
aerospace engineering so what we were
you thinking back then gee i want to be
general in the u.s space force that
isn't invented yet like what's what's
going through your head not even close
i
i am a first-generation college student
in my family and so
that was a big deal
yeah you know yet you could have done
just a little less yeah
like
seriously
you're the first to do it you're just
like i'm just going to blow up the road
behind me for everybody else right
you're just going to be completely
embarrassed if you try to follow in
these footsteps yeah i'm the first
generation i'm now a major general i'm
head of all space and uh yeah you know
and i got 17 000 people reporting to me
so your lordship i want you to imagine
you're my brother who's three years
younger than me yeah it doesn't go
really well yeah that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah
okay so what was what was your brain
transition from getting a quote simple
engineering degree to landing
as an officer in the military so i think
i entered dr tyson the same way many
people come into the military for
college i mean my parents couldn't
afford to send me to college uh the air
force offered me a
four-year degree if i was willing to
pursue pursue stem science technology
engineering or math uh i took
aeronautical engineering at embry rental
aeronautical university in daytona beach
florida it was far enough away from home
that i didn't see my parents every
weekend but i could go home to
jacksonville florida where my family was
when i wanted to
um i was a space coast baby so space was
always interesting to me growing up with
the shuttle program and all those space
coast is the east coast of florida
in the northern section where where we
have cape canaveral so i don't know how
many people know that that's just called
space coast but it certainly is and and
glad to hear that you had a little bit
of space baptism from that exposure okay
go keep going but but i thought you know
i was going to do my for and done
because when you take a scholarship you
owe four years back to the military but
i fell in love with the people and the
mission uh and here i am 29 years later
so uh it's been really good to me and
i've learned a ton and now i've crossed
over three months ago from the air force
to the space force and it's just been
amazing amazing ride
so here
i just want to ask very quickly because
it's a just a bit of an aside a bit of a
bit of a digestion who came up with the
name space force because i'm just going
to say it's it's so very clever no i
think the the name united states space
force identifies the domain that we work
in and it's a warfighting domain and
then the force that executes just like
you have the united states air force the
united states army uh again they
typically associate with the domain that
they operate in
okay now so we we've got to get to
breast tax here because there's some
percent of the public i don't think it's
the majority but it's enough of them for
me to bring the question to you
uh they're concerned that space force is
sort of the escalation
of military tensions in the world and
that it's
it's just we're just gonna have uh laser
fights and and and bombs in space and i
don't think people see this
as a positive step
as opposed to being either neutral or a
peaceful step for the future of the
security of the world could you just
react to that
i i totally understand and understand as
a military member i don't want to see a
war that extends into space that's not
good for anyone that's not good for our
coalition partners commercial industry
anybody so we don't want to see that but
like any other uh department we have to
be ready to fight and win our nation's
wars wherever they go uh so
again our enemies are showing and the
threats have evolved uh general raymond
and general dickinson have both
testified to many things that are on
orbit today uh by our strategic
adversaries or competitors china and
russia that exist as we speak right now
so
it's not that the threats are coming the
threats are on orbit and we have to be
prepared to uh respond uh and react and
protect our assets and for those who who
are into our archives we actually have
general raymond as a guest on an earlier
episode of star talk so you can dig that
out of our files
when you say threat
what exactly are you referring to uh as
a threat when it comes to uh our low
earth orbit uh positions or any any
earth orbit or any earth orbit
so so you have direct descent uh
anti-satellite munitions so uh asaps uh
for both low-earth orbit and beyond and
that's been proven by the chinese in
2007 they launched an asad and killed
one of their own hit one of their own
dead weather birds in 2007 blew it into
thousands of pieces we are still
tracking to this day uh and will be for
generations to come uh so that created
un long-lived debris that will affect
everyone in the domain not just the
department of defense
and it'll affect china as well right
that's like peeing in your own in your
own bathtub yeah yeah i mean what what
were they doing is that like a guy who
starts a fight by punching himself in
the face
you know just like i'll show you how
tough i am
like what the heck what we'll do is
we've got more baja coming in in the
third segment and that's his total
expertise so so let's uh that's a nice
seed planted for that so let's let's
keep going on what what other
threats do we see
so the other options that are out there
again general raymond and general
dickinson in their congressional
testimonies talked about both of these
one is a chinese robotic arm so they
have a robotic arm in geosynchronous
orbit that they are doing testing with
so if you've seen the show space force
one of my favorites
uh in the second episode you see the the
sound let's be clear that's a comedy
right
steve carell okay
and when you see them cut the solar
panel off of the satellite funny haha
but when you talk about today on orbit
the chinese have a robotic arm that's
exactly what they could do they could
rip off a piece of a satellite or hurt
it in some way uh throw it into an
unusable orbit so again that robotic arm
is very scary in a very high interest
orbit for communications missile warning
and all the capabilities that we depend
on to protect and communicate with our
forces
the second one again is what we call the
russian nesting doll so the russians
launched into low earth orbit a nesting
primary vehicle launched an orbital
engagement system that came out of that
satellite and then from that satellite
came a kinetic kill vehicle it shadowed
one of our high value assets in low
earth orbit for a period of time that
again to us uh was not appropriate
because they were testing that
capability and instead of testing
against their own capabilities they were
shadowing and testing near one of our
high value assets
so again
not not good happening every day and on
orbit and their capabilities continue to
grow and again those are all the unclass
level we've uh
recognized that security is important uh
for us but at the same time how do we
portray the american people what are the
threats on orbit it's really hard
to understand because satellites don't
have moms right no one can understand
what the threats are in orbit because
you don't see them every day as you do
in the other domains and you get
pictures up so it's really hard to
communicate
to the american people what this is and
the show is really important to doing
that and so i appreciate that you do
these because it makes it real to folks
it helps them understand uh some very
complex things as the boss says space is
hard how do you translate that to the
american people
interesting very uh
perceptive point that satellites don't
have family that you can then get them
to plea for their safety but satellites
do have financial value not only in the
value of the hardware itself but in the
marketplace that it enables be it uber
or tinder or bank records or anything
else
is there some clear way and is it your
job
to communicate
how
deep that threat can be to our way of
life or there's some other agency that
whose job that is and not yours no
that's absolutely ours i mean we if
there is a threat to the american way of
life in the american way war if we lose
these capabilities i mean gps i'm a
former gps squadron commander i mean one
of the things we talk about with all the
time with gps is not only the navigation
signal which we all use every day to
travel the world but also the timing
signal the timing signal is used to
stick many of our
cell towers and communication networks
that you use every day as well as the
new york stock exchange so imagine if
that timing signal is gone what does
that do to trade what does that do to
commerce i mean those are
uh
things that happen every day general one
of general dickinson as the us space
command commander slogans is never a day
without space so again absolutely his
wheelhouse is the base command commander
to defend and protect uh all those
capabilities and most people don't even
know i mean i try i really i try but
they don't know how much of your
everyday life is touched by space assets
even beyond simple gps i mean that i
don't think people appreciate that and
so i think there
there's a task ahead of us all in this
to try to communicate
um the value of what you are doing
and do these satellites that you guys
are uh responsible for uh for a lack of
a better term do they include uh private
sector uh property though that's a good
good question yeah
no we're just going to understand your
lawrence great question
she's sticking with that title
you know what see but this is the
difference between civilians and people
in the military people in the military
like oh you want to be that i will make
you regret that
chuck you're gonna have to change your
twitter handle that's what's gonna
happen
i think lordship nice has a great ring
to it sometimes it actually i hate to
admit it but it does it does yeah yeah
so anyway yeah that's a great question
so what i would say is um
we track 32 000 pieces on orbit of that
32 000 about 5 000 are active satellites
or active objects uh and from that then
about 10 percentage of those are
government resources for the united
states of america whether that be
department offense or other agencies but
government capability
when you guys did this interview with
general raymond in 2019 we had about
1800 objects that were live on orbit and
that was quoted in that podcast today
think 5 000. we've almost tripled and
you might say well why did we triple
that's not government
because i'm only 10 we're only 10 of
that the the triple has happened in the
commercial market the cost of launch has
reduced based on the number of folks who
are bringing that capability to bear and
reducing launch costs and now you see
companies engaging in building
satellites uh spacex with starlink uh
getting ready to launch 100 at a throw
to get 5g in low orbit one web i mean
there are many companies now that are
launching satellites uh and we only see
that continuing to explode so by the way
charles and i have our co-authors on
papers that use data from the hubble
space telescope which is a honkering
satellite up there
you know not enough people think of it
as a satellite it's a satellite but it's
a big one the size of a greyhound bus
you know i'd like to think that some
major portion of your responsibility is
protecting that telescope i'm just
saying between you and me absolutely and
we do that day in and day out to ensure
nothing from a debris perspective or
another active payload would conjunct or
hit you uh also as any of those uh
objects re-enter earth's atmosphere
we're tracking those and reporting those
working with state department if we
predict a landing in another country uh
or how that would uh happen in through
u.s space command so that those are
happening day in and day out and that's
our bread and butter of our job i think
what we'll change here shortly which we
really need to normalize the domain and
this is all space traffic management
right how do we operate
on orbit satellite to satellite and is
free and fair for all is the department
of commerce so the there's an ndaa a
national defense authorization act that
says the department of commerce will be
the lead for space traffic management we
have been doing that as the government
because the government had the lion's
share
of of capability on orbit due to the
cost of entry but as i said earlier you
can see now it's tripled it's in the old
days
yeah yeah so we need an faa for space
i'm i'm reminded that noah the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration
is a branch of the department of
commerce and so here we are monitoring
climate and weather recognizing its
direct impact on the economic security
of the nation so charles do you have a
question yes it would it would be great
thank you i have two very short
questions if that's okay uh first of all
um
you mentioned domain
right as we know the united states
generally considers space as being 50
miles on up
so i presume that your domain certainly
starts at 50 miles perhaps before then
but how far up does it go does it go
past the moon does it go to the moon or
lunar orbit does it go to mars in other
words is space force really the force
for the domain of the universe itself
or just a little bit less than that no
general
he wants you to protect from here to the
edge of the the cosmic horizon right
that's what that sounds like so what i
would say is uh as the u.s space command
unified command plan so when you're a
combatant commander you have a unified
command plan that defines what your area
of responsibility is
every geographic combatant commander has
that so whether your european command
pacific command you have a defined area
of responsibility for general dickinson
as the u.s space command commander the
unified command plan signed by the sec
def and the president states that he is
responsible for 100 kilometers above the
earth's surface to infinity
and beyond
and beyond
that
completely general question jen will go
back to that document and you have to
put in and beyond you have to go please
do that and by the way yeah you have to
stretch it out in tight you know
and
in all seriousness uh to dr lou's
question is i would say to you day to
day dr lou we are concerned mostly with
going in so 22 500 miles and into that
hundred kilometer area is where we focus
day to day geo is is it's code for
geostationary yes
when you talk about the moon and you
talk about where we're going in 2024 by
putting astronauts on the moon to stay
where elon musk is in his adventure to
get to mars
you can see though that in the next five
to ten years uh it will become geo and
out and how far out is appropriate uh
one of the discussions we've had is
about geo times 14 and you might say hey
deanna dr lou may know this answer but
geo times 14 is where you have a three
body problem between the earth the moon
and the sun and so we're trying to
define requirements in the military of
how far out do we want to start looking
for the future to then build
requirements and build systems and and
do budget requests etc for all of that
so uh
that sounds like the lagrangian point i
guess right you have to start yes you
have to start paying very close
attention to the garage surfaces and and
lisa ju figures and things like that
right right okay now wait a minute no no
no no no no no lagrange what is you
can't just drop in
no no i really i would love to ask one
more question and this is actually from
my educators hat if that's okay general
burton you bet um first uh let me just
thank you on behalf of so many of us uh
for your service to the country to
keeping us safe to making sure that our
lives are are as good as they are so
thank you so much for that
now there are people
young men and women and uh young people
all over who are looking at you and
saying how can i be
general burt not just education wise but
like your opinions your thoughts when a
young person comes to me and and says
how can i become someone on the space
force how can i become a guardian um
they're going to be looking to you and
because you know what what would you
tell them as
completely unironically you are indeed
the very model of a modern major general
that was a long walk around the block to
get to that so to to land on the left
gilbert and sullivan sullivan
payload right yeah worth the effort
right yeah it was worth it
but the question is serious actually
seriously no i agree and that was a long
wait but that is awesome i like that um
no what i would say is
again to join uh the space force we see
ourselves as a digital service so i'm
looking for young folks who have
innovative minds who want to ask why i
love three-year-olds ask why why do we
do things the way we do it's a new
service we have a clean slate we can do
anything we want in any way we want we
value artificial intelligence machine
and machine communication obviously the
whole exploration of space and where
this is going to go and if i were to
meet a young 21 year old graduating
college or a young 18 year old entering
college i would say hey the the sky is
not the limit it's endless uh and and
there's opportunity that in their
generation they will be operating and
living in space
uh in their lifetime and and how do we
uh go to that new frontier so i think
it's very exciting i think we're looking
for educated folks with stem degrees we
again obviously what we do is very
difficult and complex so we're looking
for that academic rigor and background
to get out there and get after it but
innovation and asking why are the two
key things and i think this generation
is stock full of it uh and ready to come
hard in the space force and we have not
had a recruiting problem it's been uh
we're very small and lean uh purposely
focused on mission but we have not we've
seen again beating the doors down in
every aspect to join the space force
whether that be as officers or as
enlisted members i need you to confirm
are there are the new recruits actually
called space cadets
just to be clear
guardians guardians
guardians sweet
guardians oh man now i want to join so
now it could be star-lord nice
let me ask chuck chuck i mean let me ask
you charles do you think the first
person to walk on mars is alive now yeah
like elementary school or absolutely
yeah okay maybe not elementary school
maybe even in college i agree whoa wow
that's really pretty pretty cool all
right we're gonna take a quick break
we're gonna lose charles dr charles liu
i know but yeah but we got more coming
in chuck i got okay we're not going to
leave you hanging here call me anytime
i'll be around
charles you will are have been r and for
will ever always be our geek in chief
yes
we'll be right back with the general and
lord nice when star talk returns
we're back star talk we're talking about
the space force what is it what's going
on what are they up to what are their
priorities
and how is it protecting all that we
care and love about our modern lives got
my co-host chuck nice jack hey hey hey
great to be here and my special guest is
u.s space force major general deanna
burt
general bert uh welcome this is your
second segment with us and thanks for
hanging on uh and and giving us this
much time
we're also going to bring in in a couple
of minutes
someone who is now i get to call him a
veteran of star talk
we have professor morba ja
he's an associate professor in the
department of aerospace engineering and
engineering mechanics at ut austin
and i would think in terms of what he
specializes in we get to call him an
astro dynamicist and space
environmentalist sounds like we're going
to need some more of those going forward
if environmentalism movement moves from
the surface of the earth to space itself
but we'll get to his expertise in a
minute uh i just want to
work our way into that and and ask
general
when we think of space warfare we're not
always thinking of
sort of uh
machines that would like turn off the
switch of a of a satellite or redirect
it we're thinking of weapons that
destroy
and you mentioned in the second segment
uh was it 2007 the chinese
sort of did a kinetic kill on one of
their own satellites i think we did
shortly after that as well
so what is that
what does that mean
for the present and future of the space
environment
well i think it's again as i said
earlier no one wants a war that extends
into space because those types of
weapons particularly anti-satellite
weapons that we talked about create huge
debris fields that affect everyone and
so again not not good
so what we have to prevent against is
how do we work in a multi-domain so
thinking all of our other service
partners how would we keep that
anti-satellite munition from launching
left of launch i don't want that to
launch we don't want to see that debris
so how would we work uh with all the
other services in a joint fight to make
sure that that didn't launch and use
other capabilities so a fight that could
extend into space doesn't necessarily
mean it has a space answer it could have
a land or a cyber or special ops or
another element that helps us take away
that threat particularly ground-based
threats and so while that saddle while
that anti-satellite weapon is on route a
big part of that is through earth's
atmosphere so you might expect the air
force to have something to say about
that and i want to jump in and and help
protect you on the bottom end
uh could be
i i think the other piece is how do we
also make ourselves resilient on orbit
how do i make myself a hard target how
do i get those indications of warning
that if in fact it does a launch how do
i
confuse the seeker or the end game to
hit me so that there's a miss
so you want to duck is what you're
saying
you want to duck and cover we've heard
that one before that many decades ago uh
one more question before we we bring in
uh uh our astro dynamicist
is the
uh the when we took out our own
satellite if i remember if memory serves
it was relatively lower in orbit so that
most if not all of the debris that we
created has already fallen out of orbit
whereas the chinese satellite was much
higher up where there's much less air
resistance to drag it down
and burn up did my am
i remembering this correctly no
absolutely uh as you will recall the the
satellite that we shot down was a large
dead satellite that was re-entering and
it was such a size and the amount of
fuel that was on it we were worried
about it re-entering intact and hurting
the population so again hit it at a much
lower orbit as you said such that the
debris and gravity
would work again work for us and bring
it all in or burn it up uh in smaller
pieces so that's exactly what we did the
chinese again did that more to higher
orbit
in low earth orbit and it then pushed
debris up into other regimes as well as
into low earth orbit and as i said
earlier we're still tracking debris from
that and will be for decades to come see
now what what you just explained there i
believe it's called american
exceptionalism okay
very much even when we blow stuff up
we're cleaner about it
so it's also called thinking ahead so i
don't
i just don't even understand how the
chinese could do something like that but
so let's bring in professor john just so
you know professor um uh the good
general here has
has uh bestowed a new title on our
comedian so
chuck nice is now lord nice and she
refers him as the lordship we'll we will
require that of you for this remaining
segment just so you know absolutely
absolutely i'm here to serve
[Laughter]
so
dr zha how many satellites are in orbit
approximately yes dead and living okay
well so so so if we talk about dead and
living look we're we're talking upwards
of like you know
six six to ten thousand of these things
dead and living uh but the living is
four thousand but if we include the dead
stuff then you know ten thousand or so
um total stuff is like 30 000 things but
most of the 30 000 things aren't
complete satellites they're fragments
and that's no
so wait are you telling me we're
tracking and this is for both of you
major general and dr uh ja
are we tracking and how far down can we
track in terms of size these some of
this has to be debris some of it has as
you say uh
the dead things
what can we track yeah so look i mean
the so the largest thing clearly is the
space station right so we don't have an
issue with that um but when we go on the
smaller stuff but just to be clear this
space station is the size of a football
field so
so so so goodness goodness to say we can
we can track that but um
yeah right
if we can't do that we're in big trouble
we're in big trouble i i think i could
track that with a pair but now you know
i could exactly so with a pair of
binoculars from my roof so so this is
what i'm calling it's not even low
hanging fruit chuck this is like fruit
on the ground turning rancid right is
your ability to like yeah
but uh yeah the smaller stuff really
we're talking about softball size is
really is really kind of the smaller
stuff and um
people clearly want to be able to get to
like uh you know golf ball size things
but that's really hard to do so i would
say softball size is kind of on the
smaller range of things so i'll ask you
wait wait i'm sorry neil because now i'm
scared to death from what you just said
softball-sized things traveling at 17
000 miles an hour that's crazy so
uh
charles anything traveling
chuck anything traveling in seventy
thousand
i don't get hit by a softball or a golf
ball that's true exactly i got a feeling
you won't be taking a bass
but here's here's here's what scares me
what do you do when you track it and you
find out that it might become injurious
to something else how did what then what
okay this is going to hit whatever now
what for the things we track uh again as
he mentioned softball size and lower the
only thing i would say is again i said
earlier 32 000 objects is what we're
tracking today roughly in a 5 000 active
so when we talk about active versus
inactive so if it's two inactive objects
uh hey we're watching crash up derby
occur there's not much to do
we just have to watch the two objects
what we call conjunct or hit each other
and we predict that and we watch that
closely because then that creates more
debris right when they hit
if it's a live object and a dead object
obviously we're contacting the owner
operator of the live object and giving
them that information and asking
them for consideration for move to
protect their payload this is called
safety of flight operations that we do
here every day at the combined space
operation center you have to have to
tell people you got to tell people
if i understand correctly almost all
satellites
retain a little bit of reserve fuel
to adjust their position
either to give themselves a new boost
because the atmosphere is dragging on
them or to avoid a collision is that
correct absolutely so everyone has a
certain amount of gas and what they can
maneuver or not and again when we talk
to those owner operators of those active
satellites what kind of gas budget do
they have and can they move uh if it's
two live objects again we make the uh
make the notification to both owner
operators and then the discussion uh is
between the two of how they're going to
move we do this with both the chinese
the russians commercial our coalition
partners it doesn't matter who you are
that mission is done every day from the
combined space operations center here at
vandenberg space force base wow
so
professor job we all saw the movie
gravity okay and that was a documentary
i'm told not just well you know anytime
sandra bullock uh
and clooney are in that for sure it's
got to be educational it's educational
so
um my favorite is that he comes up to
the spaceship and is knocking on the
outside door but she was imagining it
but that was just a funny little scene
that's right uh so uh in that they do
however
portray a very real effect
and i'm told it's called the kessler
effect could you just briefly tell us
what that is yeah so look there's
there's this gentleman don kessler
worked for nasa for a long time uh came
up with this hypothesis that um
given given the the increase in crowding
of things on orbit and things going bump
in in in the night that there there
would be a tipping point as it were
where even if you didn't launch anything
else
the population is self-growing because
things keep on colliding and you can't
prevent those collisions from happening
so that's i think loosely what people
understand as this kessler effect or
kessler syndrome
so that would mean that there's a
catastrophic point where it's just a
roller derby up there and everything or
space derby everything is colliding
making more and more debris colliding
even more and then all space assets gets
completely wiped out a never-ending
chain reaction right right is that kind
of a chain reaction thing
well so so this is where uh
people that fully embrace the kessler
syndrome would say yes it's this chain
reaction never ending um i i'm not a big
believer in never ending things uh so so
i would say that equilibrium at some
point would be reached but equilibrium
can also mean orbits become unusable so
so the end effect is an orbit becoming
unusable and clearly we don't want to
see that happen
but i think i think that's only unusable
so i guess i'm not a
fatalist and that it's all going to be
terrible yes we care about this as the
military but i think one is being an
owner operator and as you said sir
having the gas to be able to control
your satellite and do orbit and station
keeping properly and when notified being
a a good operator of your capability
second is when you get to what we would
call your min fuel to deorbit or move to
an unusable orbit you're able to do that
and that's you know what we would say is
that norms of behavior of how you should
operate day to day so it's free and fair
for all lastly i would say we were just
at space symposium last week and a lot
of discussion about debris removal so i
think this kessler discussion also
posits that you wouldn't have any debris
or trash truck capability to go pick up
debris
i i think that's absolutely uh
a business case for industry and
commercial because again i go back to if
the military were to do that let's say i
have an arm that goes and picks up trash
or does things it could be dual use so
you don't want that to come from a
military perspective you want that to
come from industry and commercial uh to
be the trash trucks or the pickup and to
be fully transparent and they would be
asked to service and go pick up things
or put more gas on something that's
that's capable of continuing mission
uh but has run out of something that's
uh like a propellant that it needs more
gas so i think there's options here to
not be so fatalistic we just haven't
produced the technologies uh yet to get
there so what about other things that
could slam into satellites or even into
earth like asteroid threats
the hubble telescope itself has a safe
mode
where the lid closes and it turns
its underbelly its sensitive underbelly
towards earth
during
meteor showers of high expectation so
that the micrometeoroids that come
through and light up the sky
would have a minimum
lasting quote impact on the telescope if
it hit so
in your portfolio of things to worry
about
beyond russia china and possibly other
uh other adversaries uh is there do you
have
natural
uh disasters on your list
oh absolutely every day in the
environment as you know dr tyson is it's
the environment is very harsh uh from
solar flares various uh emissions from
the sun
that impact the satellites as you
mentioned asteroids those kinds of
things we work closely with nasa uh to
be able to predict and talk to those
media meteor showers is again that's
more in their wheelhouse of tracking and
how they do deep space work
but that is shared with us uh and again
we work to how do we protect our
payloads just as you talked about
flipping the hubble we we would be
looking at those same kind of options to
limit any damage to our capabilities as
well is there any kind of regulatory
global commission
that
tells what countries what they can and
cannot do i remember china they
deorbited a satellite or something i
don't know what it was but they were
like oh yeah by the way we don't know
where it's going to come down
i remember that remember that right
and
i mean like who who yeah so he's kind of
watching no no it wasn't just that it
wasn't just that truck they launched the
the the booster and
and yes professor john correct me if i'm
wrong they had a booster that did did
not contain the capacity to control
its descent back to earth and which
leaves it kind of random uh yeah
professor did i get that right yeah yeah
that that's exactly right and so so look
i mean we have international law
codified in things like outer space
treaty and conventions with the un and
all that other stuff but you know the
language is widely interpreted and the
implementation is like you know
randomly assessed at best and isn't that
from 1968 or something
yeah
yeah 1967 right
wow
i know the only other argument i would
offer that other regulatory
organizations that are involved
obviously you have the fcc the federal
communications commission so again when
we start talking about satellite
communications whether they be in low
earth orbit
or a geosynchronous orbit the
deconfliction of frequencies so people
aren't stepping on each other
or you know interfering with each other
uh intentionally as we work the design
the other one is the international
telecommunications union and that's who
decides the has the slots out at geo so
every one degree out in the
geosynchronous belt uh our our slots
that people can uh
go out and register for and co-locate
together so there are multiple
satellites that fly in that one degree
box and basically station keep and
operate day in and day out together so
it can be done
i think some of the concerns moving
forward is the proliferation of low
earth orbit uh like we talked about
starlink and oneweb uh in on the order
of uh i think starlink i heard yesterday
their new uh satellite
registry that they're trying to do with
the fcc is 25 000 satellites and low
earth orbit yeah yeah that's a lot
that's that that's pretty crazy you know
but so so how do you regulate how they
operate in that in that domain and again
that station keeping and so we don't get
this kessler effect we talked about
earlier so again how do how do you
regulate that this is some of the part i
talked about earlier dr tyson about why
the department of commerce and being the
owner of space traffic management and
getting them on board will be important
uh the department of defense has played
that role and and will continue to do so
uh and partner with the department of
commerce as they stand up but you can
see the value that we needed there's a
regulatory requirement and even
international regulatory element kind of
like the faa is for air yeah
same thing for space yeah
i think getting to the lordship's point
uh there is no there is no global you
know star trek federation that's going
to do this it's all up to individual
countries so the countries actually have
to get together and say we are the
bottleneck to all this stuff and we we
we are the ones that are responsible for
providing authorization and continuing
supervision of all these folks let's
agree to a set of standards norms of
behavior that we can then hold our
people you know accountable to and i
think on the one point that the general
made really quick on the dual use type
stuff look when you go with commercial
people that have the grappling arms
that's also dual use technology so i
think that the main thing is
when i was a security policeman guarding
nukes at maostrom i was taught a threat
required intent opportunity and
capability so so the thing that really
separates hazard from threat is the
intent piece so what kind of behaviors
can we put in place to basically put
away this threat stuff so we don't
assume that everything is out to get us
necessarily because the capability and
opportunity for harm are always going to
be present with dual use technologies so
dr job brings up a great point it's it's
understanding space domain awareness not
just space traffic management space
domain awareness is more isr
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance in space what is your
pattern of life how do you normally
operate is this unusual for you is this
your norm how do you typically station
keep all of those things play into that
space domain awareness
over the domain for all the players that
are there and when something is
or doesn't seem as it should be then
that's when this discussion of norms of
behavior having defined what is good now
if we see something that is bad how are
we going to respond and do it rise to
the occasion of that it needs a military
diplomatic or any of the instruments of
power that the nation can bring to bear
very really cool very important facts
there that yeah just the existence of
what could could be a threat if there's
no intent we have to that is a
conversation that's an analysis and
that's where i don't trust ai i think
people have to be in that equation ai is
stupid i mean ai is about as smart as an
earthworm man
s-i stupid intelligence yeah we're gonna
that's a whole other show by the way
we're gonna have to call it quits there
we ran over
professor john great to have you on
again thank
and and and general burt delight to meet
you for the first time and i hope this
is not the the last time we see you uh
yeah we will have continuing questions
about this domain and what it means to
earth to
americans to and and to the future of
space excellence now can i tell people
that i know a two-star general now is
that okay with you
absolutely and that at 50 cents i'll get
you a couple
all right and chuck you just got to earn
this she was describing uh one degree
boxes out there on on
so how many boxes are there
um well it's round so it's got to be
360. very good you got it okay just
checking it
i knew he was leading you in that
direction
you earned your you earned your lordship
today yes he earned star-lord right
there star-lord i love it i love it all
right that's that we really got to end
it right there uh thank you all for
making this work and making it
informative and even fun neil degrasse
tyson here for star talk as always keep
looking up
[Music]
you